welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of this new
trailer footage for the Marvels with
tickets now on sale for the release on
November 10th and this footage is
starting to hint at what it means to be
cosmically powered in the MCU beyond the
ability to take headbutts from Thanos
and if you're the scroll guia using them
I guess only some of the time in between
toggling past drax's arm there are two
promos we are looking at in this video a
spot called prepared and a ton of
footage from an introducing the marbles
featurette I'm going to break down all
the new details okay let's start with
this prepared spot it actually opens
with a recap Montage from Carol danver's
past MCU appearances up through her duel
with Thanos in endgame and then
transitions into a little moment with
darbin the villainous Creed General
played by Zoe Ashton take a look the
annihilator you took everything from me
now I'm returning the
favor she's targeting the people that I
care
about every place I C
home she's trying to start a
war what are you prepared to
do give her hell watch
me the Marvels okay darbin is a Creed
general part of the succession of
accusers that also included Ronin the
accuser from Guardians of the Galaxy and
the first Captain Marvel film the
accusers are a group of cre zealots a
highly militarized terroristic faction
that split off from the mainstream cre
militarian Society to seek their vision
of cre dominance through might and
through fear but that said the cre as a
whole have been depicted as general
as they are governed by the cre
Supreme intelligence the world mind that
gaslighted Carol Danver AKA veers and
apparently signed off on a Galaxy by
genocide of the squirrel race darb Ben
carries the cosmi rod the same type of
weapon that Ronin used that he fused
with the Power Stone and Guardians of
the Galaxy but hers also glows with a
purple glow that seems at least in part
activated by her bangle in this film she
will have that other bangle you remember
the bangal the mystery mystical cuff
that Kamala Khan came into possession of
in The Miz Marvel series kamala's
great-grandmother found the first bangle
on a severed blue arm in some ruins in
India in the early 20th century ruins
marked by the symbol of the 10 Rings
suggesting that the 10 rings and these
Bangals are both technology from the
ancient cre Empire darb Ben will use
this bangal and her cosmi Rod to curse
the holder of the other bangle Kamala
Khan and cosmically entangle Kamala Khan
with Carol daners and Monica Rambo
because all three superpowers all stem
from the same Source Cosmic radiation
that courses throughout the Universe now
some questions remain about other
cosmically empowered characters like
Gaia the squrrel daughter of Taos from
Secret Invasion who Juiced up with
Aventure DNA from the Harvest including
the DNA of Carol Danvers which gave her
Carol's Powers along with everyone
else's power it seems I know I'm also
now having questions about Ren Slayer in
loky season 2 whom we just heard in a
recording with he remains he called her
quote quite a Marvel but that might just
be me reging on that one but in this
clip darb Ben calls Carol Danvers the
annihilator and she says she took
everything from her and it's interesting
that they call her the annihilator like
that's their nickname for her maybe the
whole Cult of the accuser's nickname for
Carol danverse through her adventures
throughout the known universe she took
something from this group and I have a
theory on what that is that I'll get to
later in this video then we get a new
shot of darbin on a Cliffs side with her
hair and some interesting braids a new
wardrobe a heavy cloak draped over her
shoulders I thought this might be a
flashback but no it seems like darbin
gets the bangal in this movie and she
has it in the shot she's striking it
with the cosmic Rod releasing a purple
blast of energy followed by this
interesting shot of a building with
curved wavy architecture collapsing and
if you look closely at the fleeing
humanoids in that shot they all got
green heads yeah these are Scrolls so
could here we actually be seeing Emperor
dr's Colony that was established
sometime after the destruction of the
srel home World scr because Emperor duoo
was mentioned in episode two of secret
Invasion I sent out the call and every
scr that isn't in Emperor Georgia's
Colony they answer now in the comics
droy theu edu was a scroll scientist
from the head priest who invents the
very first super Scrolls in the MCU he's
the current emperor of whatever
surviving Scrolls there are in the
universe and they have some other colony
I think we're going to see it here and
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video October is a stressful time
of year school has started the holidays
are approaching there's less Sun if you
are struggling with something don't
force yourself to Bear it alone get help
from a licensed therapist with better
help starting therapy can be hard the
right therapist for you may not be in
your area and some people struggle with
the face to- face interaction of therapy
with better help you can have your
therapy sessions as a phone call as a
video chat or even via messaging if you
prefer that whatever is the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
just click the link in the description
and answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are better help will
then match you with a therapist from
their Network that's right for you and
if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a
therapist for no additional cost without
stressing about insurance or who's in
your network or anything like that
mental health is quite the journey but
it is an important one so start your
journey towards better mental health
click the link in the description or
visit betterhelp.com neww rockstars to
help support this Channel and get you
10% off your first month with better
help then we get a quick shot of a
different alien world which could be the
cre home world of Hala we see this Jade
color angular architecture an energy
blast lights up the sky I have some
thoughts about what's going on here that
connect to my theory of why they call
Carol Danver the anilor we'll get to it
a bit later then we see a new look at
Carol as she has realized darbin is
attacking every world that she calls
home so just a recap for everybody that
would include Earth as well as whatever
scroll Colony we're visiting here as
well as alad that's the planet where
Prince Yan lives and maybe even the home
world of Hala I wouldn't put it pass the
accusers to attack Hala now there's a
new shot of Nick Fury and Kamala Khan's
family including moaan YF and amaron
with some yellow skinned cadetes from
the saber space station they are
deboarding this Landing shuttle with
Flur and hopping around this park a few
of these Cadets actually roll around in
the grass now if this park is in New
York or Jersey City this could be part
of the shot where the landing shuttle
passes the Statue of Liberty that is
bronze colored fact that is bronze
giving us a bit of continuity connecting
to Spider-Man no way home and just a
reminder that if you go re-watch Miss
Marvel they did recolor the Statue of
Liberty one of the establishing shots
from its normal green color to bronze as
it was a no way home so that this shot
would work I guess either way in that
shot of the shuttle passing by the
Statue of Liberty you can see a flurin
all of its tentacles released on the
inside probably in the process of
attacking a Cadet so now Fury asks
Monica Rambo what are you prepared to do
and this is a real weird shot in the
trailer if you look at the shelves
behind Fury there are some reddish pink
objects that kind of look like either
brains or egg sacks something
extraterrestrial if you look closely
Fury is totally holding one of these
things in his hands so I'm wondering if
these things could be half lurk and
reproduced like some kind of weird
flurin placental sacks or egg sacks like
they might be in the process of hatching
all of those many many flerkens that we
see in all the other trailer shots so
next darb Ben uses her cosm rod and I
love calling it a cosm rod it's such a
silly stupid name but that is what it's
called she is skting to a halt here
tracing a curved scratch into the
surface it looks like she and Carol are
going to be fighting each other on top
of the ship off the coast of alad and
again that is the home world where Carol
left her husband Prince Yan this is a
planet where everyone speaks in rhymed
couplets and it sounds like in the movie
it's a musical planet where they're
singing so is the planet of Aladin
doomed will this movie introduce this
operatic singing planet and then
immediately destroy it while the
destruction and the booms and the bangs
all be sync to Beasty Boys Intergalactic
like pretty much every trailer is okay
let's move on to some new shots in the
featurette Carol and Goose exit her
spacecraft by passing through this
barrier wall and then immediately
spacewalking and this barrier reminds me
of the technology that we saw in
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 that
separated the high evolutionary ship
with nowhere but then a quick shot of
Carol Monica and Kamala on Carol's ship
looking at this star map with planets
and then hexagonal frames around those
planets hexagon as a shape is really
important because that is the shape of
the unn grid that's how they hop between
galaxies they're essentially wormholes
and there seems to be something broken
about the unn in this movie that could
be connected to the cosmic intang lement
curse like the way darb Ben cursed them
she's kind of siphoning radiation from
this grid that courses throughout the
Universe and allows these wormholes to
exist and as long as this curses in
place they can't really hop from Galaxy
to Galaxy also on the star map we see
some curved lines snaking around them to
connect them and in the shot of Carol we
see these planets are actually numbered
we see planet GH 528 Planet S3 and then
Planet ed3 something reminder that the
Creed designation for Earth AKA Tera is
planet c-53 so I've been dying for some
kind of geographical map in the MCU
either showing how all the different
planets are connected maybe someday how
the Multiverse is connected and hey if
this movie starts to do it mission
accomplished okay we see the Battle of
alad as pran's Forces fight to cre
soldiers Monica Rambo runs and phase
shifts right through Yan and the cre
that he's fighting now we know that
Monica Rambo can manipulate
electromagnetic energy and in wav Vision
episode 9 she shifted the light of her
body to allow bullets to phase through
her torso so to get the shot they must
have had Tiana Paris on a different set
and then plated her in like notice how
after she clears them she's totally
being lit by completely different light
sources than the fighters are Carol
Danvers will have two different Captain
Marvel costumes in this movie one that
she starts the movie with with the red
top and the blue everything else and
then another one that we see in
different trailer shots with duller
shades of Navy and red with the navy
blue on top wondering why she changes
costumes like what happens to her then
we get a behind the scen shot of the
three leads rapping on the day that
they're shooting the scroll sequences
surrounded by squirrel civilians it
looks like there's one on the far right
that has flowers on his head so maybe
it's some kind of wedding ceremony that
they're celebrating we see darbin in a
long hallway as a silhouette stands in a
glowing room destroying whatever
Machinery is inside I want to say this
Machinery kind of looks like the world
Forge that we saw in eternals but I
actually think that this might be
connected to the shot at the Jade
building that has the blast that I
talked about earlier I think we might
learn that Carol has destroyed the cre
Supreme intelligence that could be what
she took from the cre people why they
call her the annihilator this could be
the temple on Hala that we saw in the
Captain Marvel film where veers first
met the cre Supreme intelligence like
Carol Danvers based off of her hatred of
her time with the cre could have just
said you know what no Society in the
known Galaxy should have this kind of
Technology because it just leads to
really bad and that could have made
her a really big enemy of the most
zealous of the cre and that would be the
accusers and lastly this shot of
kamala's mother MBA breaking a flower
pot on the head of this C Soldier MBA
what are you doing leave it to the
Marvels to take care of this stuff okay
I want to hear your hottest takes for
this Marvel's film in the comments below
are we going to see a scroll genocide in
this movie are we going to see the creas
Supreme Intelligence being destroyed is
Silver Surfer going to make a cameo
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network you can follow me
on all social platforms at eaos thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye
everybody
[Music]
a